hey 42 here the first motorist to be
fine for speeding in the UK with Walter
Arnold in 1896 he was doing eight miles
per hour
in a two miles per hour zone welcome to
Rick the average person who lives to be
75 will have spent six years dreaming in
the first month of its life a silkworm
puts on 10,000 times its birth weight
during World War two the crew of the
British submarine HMS Trident kept a
fully grown reindeer called Pollyanna
aboard their vessel for six weeks it was
a gift from the Russians in 1999 a four
year old girl turned yellow after
drinking too much Sunny Delight young
Neanderthal girls had bigger biceps than
an adult male human 25 million Bibles
were printed in 2011 compared to 208
million IKEA catalogs the longest
hangover in medical literature lasted
four weeks
it belonged to a 37 year old man from
Glasgow the cat synclavier
or cats piano was a musical instrument
made out of cats designed by 17th
century German scholar Athanasius
Kircher it consisted of a row of caged
cats with different voice pictures who
could be played by a keyboardist driving
nails into their tails the Thais bought
in America for Father's Day each year
would stretch from New York to Rome the
Vatican City has the highest crime rate
in the world in comparison to its
population though the resident
population is only just over 800 more
than 600 crimes are committed there each
year when diagnosed with pleurisy Sir
Robert Chesser bura the inventor of
vaseline decided to coat himself in his
product from head to foot he
survived and lived to be 96 the world's
lightest metal is a hundred times
lighter than styrofoam and can rest on a
dandelion port without damaging it the
symbols used by cartoonists to indicate
swearing are called growl X's male fruit
flies rejected by females drink
significantly more alcohol the nose that
have had a successful mating encounter
light doesn't always travel at the speed
of light the slowest we've ever recorded
light traveling at is 38 miles per hour
thanks for the view subscribe for more